pues es una Cumbre que llega en un
momento complicado política y
económicamente como todos sabemos
derivado de la guerra de Rusia en
Ucrania que ha hecho que los precios del
gas se disparen que la demanda también
se dispare y que los países estén
buscando otras medidas de conseguir
energía eléctrica desafortunadamente
basándose en combustibles fósiles Como
por ejemplo el carbón además ha supuesto
Un aumento de la inflación a nivel
global algo que perjudica las economías
globales lo cual se refleja en la
voluntad que pueda haber de los países
de invertir más dinero en la lucha
contra el cambio climático el dinero
como sabemos es de los temas centrales
de siempre de estas conferencias
precisamente tú lo mencionabas en los
titulares Por fin se va a discutir se va
a meter en la agenda oficial el tema de
pérdidas y daños algo que los países en
desarrollo llevaban pidiendo y
reclamando Desde hacía años Todavía no
se ha que se llegue a cumplir el acuerdo
que en 2009 los países ya habían dicho
que cumplirían para el 2020 de entregar
100.000 millones de dólares al año para
adaptación y mitigación de los efectos
del cambio climático hasta ahora no se
han conseguido ni siquiera 84 mil
dólares así que bueno las buenas
noticias de hoy por lo menos es que se
va a discutir el tema de pérdidas de
daños que como bien decía es algo que
han estado pidiendo los países desde
hace mucho tiempo África el continente
será también el centro de varias
discusiones y de acuerdos y en cuanto a
presencias y ausencias a destacar pues
la presencia destacar más que nada puedo
empezar por ricisunak el Primer Ministro
de Reino Unido que hasta hace unos días
decía que no iba a asistir finalmente
cambió de opinión si asistirá a la cop
27 por su parte Vladimir Putin no estará
tampoco estará así sin pin pero sí
vendrá vaiden Aunque lo hará una vez que
pase estos dos primeros días de la 27 la
Cumbre de líderes debido a las
elecciones de medio término en Estados
Unidos vaiden entonces nuestra presente
sino hasta el 11 de noviembre más o
menos